معنى من اسطنبول مراسل الجزيره عامر لافي
عامر هذه تغييرات ربما الاسم الاكثر لفتا
للنظر او يعني يتحدثون كثيرا عنها كان في
دان ولكن في العموم ما الذي يمكن قراءته
في هذه التشكيله الحكوميه لاردوغان في
بدايه ولايته الرئاسيه الثالثه
نعم محمد يعني
كما ذكرتم قبل قليل وان كان هناك التغيير
كبير في هذه الحكومه فقط وزيران من
الحكومه السابقه تبقيا في هذه الحكومه وكل
الوزراء تم تغييرهم لكن وفقا لكثير من
المراقبين هنا يعني الوسائل الاعلام
التركيه والمحللون يعتبرون انه لن يكون
هناك تغييرا كبيرا على اداء هذه الحكومه
في معظم الملفات باستثناء ملف واحد ربما
وهو الملف الاقتصادي تحدثنا عنها كان
فيدان نعم هو كان رئيس المخابرات التركيه
لكنه كان يعني يتحكم ويدير ويشرف على
الكثير من الملفات الخارجيه التي كان يعني
يعمل بها
وبالتالي يعتبر الكثيرين عثمان بان ما
سيجري هو امتداد لما كان يقوم به على
الاعتبار ان فدان هو كان موجود في هذه
التنسيقات وفي
اداء الحكومه واداء الجمهوريه التركيه في
ملفها الخارجي ولن هناك الكثير من التغيير
معظم الوزراء ايضا كذلك تحدثتم ايضا عن
وزير الدفاع وزير الدفاع هو قائد الاركان
السابق خلوص يكار الوزير السابق هو كان
قائد الاركان السابق وعلى ما يبدو ان هذه
قد تصبح عاده في الجمهوريه التركيه بان
يصبح وزير الدفاع هو قائد الاركان السابق
دولار هو وزير القائد الاركان السابق كما
ذكرنا لكن نعود الى الملف الاقتصادي الملف
الاقتصادي هو الذي يتوقع ان يشمل او ان
يحصل فيه تغيير كبير على الاعتبار انه في
الفتره السابقه كان اردوغان يعتمد سياسه
الاقتصاديه مختلفه عما كان في السابق هنا
نقصد طبعا العمل الدائم على خفض الفائده
واصراره على خفض الفائده كحل وحيد لخفض
التضخم الكل يعرف ان محمد شمشك الوزير
الحالي ليرى عكس ذلك وهو ملتزم بالاداء
الدولي بالاداء العالمي للاقتصاد والاسواق
العالميه تعرف ذلك لديه علاقات كبيره
والهدف من جلب هذا الرجل هو طمانه الاسواق
العالميه وبالتالي يتوقع كثيرون ان يكون
هناك تغيير وخصوصا في موضوع الفائده وبشكل
عام في الاطار العام للاقتصاد واداء
الاقتصاد التركي اليوم حصلت عمليه تسليح
استلام وتسليم لوزاره الماليه والخزانه
ومنذ اللحظات الاولى واضح ان شمسك بدا
بارسال رسائل طمانه للمجتمع العالم
والمجتمع الاقتصادي العالمي عندما قال بان
الشفافيه
والتناء التنسيق والالتزام بالمعايير
الاقتصاديه الدوليه ستكون الاسس التي
نعتمد عليها لرفع مستوى رفاهيه مجتمعنا
شكرا جزيلا لك عامر اللافي من اسطنبول